okay good morning my name is John Mackey
I'm from Salt Works imma take principal
at ThoughtWorks and I've been working on
distributed system of architecture and
micro services for the last few years
also a member of our global take
advisory board people responsible for
publishing TechRadar if you haven't seen
Thor's technology Raider I encourage you
to have a look we had our recent
publication came out to end of November
so before I start the talk I just want
to say thank you to Indies organizes
this supported me to fly in from San
Francisco with my one and a half year
old girl sitting somewhere over there
and making it possible for me to be here
giving this talk if you I think thinking
about reflecting back on 2017 at least
for me one of the most exciting kind of
topics of systems architecture has been
the progression of micro services
infrastructure for micro services and
why the recognition of service mesh what
though though this is super exciting
it has disturbed disrupted the you know
notion of enterprise-grade centralized
API management system and its really
raised a bunch of questions and
ambiguity as where API management system
would sit in the architecture how would
service mesh and API gateways into play
and integrate so I had a bunch of
questions a few months ago and to get
asked to get some of these answers I
hosted a panel of discussions with some
of the creators of a few API gateways
and service missions in our office in
San Francisco to pick their brain so
what I want to share with you today is
first an overview of a service mission
not so much what it is there's a lot of
documentation out there but more how we
arrived at this topology and wide
service mesh then I want to share with
you a little bit about kind of the
overlap between these two counts of
technology the you know the traditional
API gateways and API management
and service mission how these two kind
of interconnect or interrelate and if
I'd really do a good job at that point
in the presentation you will have the
same questions that I had a few months
ago and from there I will talk about a
few pointers and you know kind of
metrics that you can use to make
decisions as where to use API gateways
were to use a service mission half what
the future might look like so in the
kind of Silicon Valley bubble where I am
one might say if you have been living on
earth if you haven't been living under a
rock you should have heard about service
mesh it's a harsh way of saying it I
like the German way much better if you
unless you've had tomatoes on your eyes
you must have heard about service mesh
so just the quick raise of hands who in
the room is familiar with service
mission yeah definitely I live in a
bubble so a little bit little bit about
what service missions service mission is
a dedicated infrastructure layer to have
reliable secure answer safe into service
communication in your distributed
architecture and if you building cloud
native applications more importantly if
you're building micro services or
distributed systems you definitely want
one here I quoted William Morgan he's
the co-founder of buoyant air startup in
the Bay Area and they had a service mesh
they started building one linker D about
a couple of years ago and most recently
they came out with a more kind of
lightweight version conduct the reason I
quoted him was because him and his
colleagues were working at Twitter
between 2010 and 2015 and they had a lot
of you know service down times and
reliability issues so they went through
an interesting journey to kind of come
up with this notion and they coined the
term service mesh in parallel to them a
lot of different engineering
actually teams have arrived to the to
the same topology and I will talk about
that so if we do want to build a
reliable fast and safe distributed
architecture traditionally you know in
kind of micro-services environment what
have we been doing what have we been
implementing those capabilities and and
and and before that let's let's think
about the capabilities that we need we
need to implement for a safe reliable
fast network we would need dynamic
service discovery load balancing we have
an F remote ephemeral kind of
infrastructure services come and go so
we would need to be able to find the
services dynamically and route traffic
with a load to load balanced cluster we
would need to build resiliency in the
architecture so we can you know minimize
the radius and impact of failure on the
overall system and over on the network
so you know we've been built building
retries timeouts circuit breakers and
we've been building this these
capabilities in this in the services we
would need some form of traffic
management right we have let's say a
canary release of a different version we
want to split the traffic between one
version and the other or we want to do a
B testing and based on the weight of the
traffic direct people to different
services we want to be able to trace
those kind of calls across the services
so we need observer ability with open
tracing and distributed tracing with
logs get rich telemetry of you know of
the api's and services that we are being
called what is the response time what's
the error rates you know throughput and
all the good kind of metrics that help
us really debug the system and last but
not least we need a really strong sense
of identity for the services what
service is calling us on behalf of what
in root user we're running a workload
and be able to enforce a whole bunch of
you know kind of policies around the
access control who can access call what
service and maybe in a more even complex
form and at
time of the day and under what
circumstances
I clicked way too far I'm sorry I got a
new clicker and all right that's where
I'm meant to be okay so it's great these
are the capabilities that we need to be
able to have fast reliable distributed
systems
how have we building this anyone been
trying to do any of these in your
architecture yeah so one way might have
been that we have had you know some
back-end delivery infrastructure tooling
to implement some of those capabilities
so for instance if you wanted to get
telemetry out of your processes you
might have had you know Prometheus and
Gravano sitting on top of it for
visualization to get you know those the
observable observability that you want
it for the services to be a be able to
emit those metrics we've been investing
in you know thick libraries shared
libraries across the services of an
occult service harness or service
chassis to be able to implement those
cross-cutting concerns but if you're in
a distributed environment with you know
autonomous teams possibly a polyglot
technology set or technology stack what
is the challenge with this approach what
are some of the pain points that we have
totally you have to chase all your teams
make sure they actually use the library
they have upgraded to the you know the
right version and the recent version you
need to have different implementation of
it in different languages so you know
enforcing consistency would be
challenging and you really did cupholder
versioning of this and the release of
these cross-cutting concerns to each and
every service that needs to be
independently released so what would be
the next obvious progression of this
model yes go out of process so get the
capabilities out put it in a service
proxy
deployed with your service and have the
traffic inbound outbound for the service
go through the proxy so make that
somebody else's problem and decouple it
from your code to this logical extension
of your code so the service proxies is
more one of the first steps that people
went through building kind of the
service mesh and the service proxy is
the one that out-of-the-box can give you
the tracing of the calls coming in
emitting you know a bunch of metrics
building circuit breakers and so on but
for this to function what is the next
challenge that we need to solve anyone
how do we get the configuration across
to all the proxies how do we get the
logs out back to you know a diverse set
of back-end infrastructure that we might
have so one way of doing that is having
you know a components in our network or
a modular component in a network that
hopefully exposes some api's for you to
get configuration into it to dispatch
the configuration to the practices or
practice you know pull them for the
configuration and send that made the
logs out and that's often called I think
in most cases called control plane the
data plane for the data going through
persistent control plane for the
configuration you know distributing
certificates and getting there talking
to the external backends and this is the
journey that you know folks had buoyant
and Twitter had gone through but this
hasn't been the end of the evolution of
this architecture a little while ago a
perfect magical storm happened folks
that's lift built a very efficient
service proxy called envoy for routing
both TCP and HTTP traffic they talked to
the folks at Google who've been dealing
with distributed API management
architecture for quite a long time and
they had the concept of you know service
endpoints and I think they had a few
beers with folks from IBM and decided to
build an open-source
and fairly open an extensible service
mesh technology called sto and it was
announced in May it might be worth to
talk about a few features that I'm
personally super excited when I look at
the architecture of the ACO
one of them is that the control plane it
has a nice extension kind of system that
you can extend it to talk to different
types of back-end and delivery
infrastructure
it has it exposes api's for you know
getting configuration in the other
feature that's really interesting is
that they started doing this first on
kubernetes and now I've extended it to
different schedulers but by using the
concept of pots in kubernetes which is
basically a unit health deployment a
unit of scheduling you can bundle the
deployment and scheduling of your side
car in this case called sidecar now with
your process and you can kind of inject
that into your pipeline and don't worry
about the decouple deployment and
scheduling of the two two containers and
lastly if you saw I kind of replace that
idea whole idea of the gateway with
kubernetes ingress which is responsible
for getting the outbound traffic into
the to the architecture and ability to
extend that with this you know kind of
idea of the ingress controller to to use
the same technology the proxying
technology that they've been using
within your mesh at the edge or in fact
use any technology for injecting side
cars into the mesh people have been
super excited about this and started you
know experimenting with all their own
side cars with their own control planes
linker D folks have their own control
plan playing you know replacing each
tier or working with this geo engine X
announced engine mesh back in September
they've you know you can inject nginx
as a sidecar or as the ingress
controller so it has a very nice kind of
extensibility and modularity to it
doesn't this look nice
so it's a great architecture right I'm
excited
it's the beginning there is a lot of
community support behind it but not too
fast as the medieval French philosopher
would say we've got a doubt to ask the
question and we've got to ask the
question to get to the truth so the
question that I had when I so serviced
mich was then where is the place where
API gateway and API management solutions
that we've been using for the you know
the last five years or so in this
architecture how they are going to
interplay and to think about like what
why this question was important for me
to answer and it was you know something
that really puzzled me I want to just
share a little story with you I worked
with a team I thought race we called
digital platform strategy team we build
kind of we consult a medium sized a
large so it's clients building digital
platforms these are the clients that
have really bought into the you know
platform thinking they have business
kpi's associated with the portion of
their business that goes through you
know api's they want to build modern
distributed systems architecture of my
services and very consistently the very
first question so one of the questions
they're gonna they ask us always
what API management system do I need to
get how do I need to deploy it what sort
of topology and to be frank this has
been actually a difficult question to
answer for these clients because to be
honest a lot of the vendors have moved
you know the API management systems into
a very monolithic and central piece of
architecture single point of you know
friction for configuration for a
development and it's been difficult to
recommend one and now it's become even
more difficult with service mesh so
let's step back for a minute and see
what API management systems have been
giving us right API management systems
market was estimated six hundred million
dollars
2016 and it's expected to grow to three
thousand four hundred million dollars by
2022 so you can imagine that the vendors
would want to pack as many features as
possible into the into the systems but
if you look at the last you know five
years most of the vendors have a set of
capabilities like the developer
engagement they you know they give you a
set of key nice capabilities that
developers in a self-serve way can
possibly use a portal to discover what
api's you have they can see the
documentation they can dynamically run
the documentation they can see like look
at the documentation exercise a piece of
code and see what sort of requests
responses they would get as a developer
for the service you can you know upload
your open API spec generate the
documentation you can have the community
notifications like if the version of the
API changes you can get no deviations
and you know have the commenting system
there and be able to test the API
there's a set of functionality around
API lifecycle management you know
promote your API secure it allocate API
keys to it to your clients to use it or
demote your API if you're making money
out of your API is if you have you know
you want to monetize that the whole set
of capabilities Apogee does a good job
of that for you know man tracking the
payment plans and making payments so
enforcing quotas on your API ABI
analytics is another big one basically
tracking the API you know KPIs and
generating reports capturing sharing
generating reports for stakeholders you
know people who care about what is the
usage of the API how how am i trending
in terms of the adoption of the API but
there is a particular set of
capabilities here that fall under the
API gateway or proxy components that
very much overlap what mesh does
everywhere
and those capabilities were usually
implemented by the Gateway at the edge
for the inbound traffic or the gateway
as a proxy or sometimes known as micro
gateways so then the question is what
how am I going to go about this like
between mesh and API gateway how do we
manage how do we get the best of both
worlds so the question we must be asking
is how do I pick an API management
gateway that plays nicely with service
mesh and as any good consultant would
tell you the answer is depends and one
of the things that depends on is your
kind of architecture journey where you
are in your architecture two words you
know kind of micro-services when we see
you know range of clients that we have
their architecture is often falls under
this spectrum from legacy monolithic
systems to you know kind of advanced
micro services architecture and it
really doesn't matter you might be a
post startup or startup where you might
be you know a multi-year large
enterprise so at the beginning of the
journey on this journey in this spectrum
you start with kind of some sort of a
legacy system that use your systems are
usually monolithic they could be you
know a node application or they could be
a cobble cobble application but what
happens is that the the monolithic
legacy is still containing most of the
logic and most of the data but for to
support some sort of a 21st century user
experience for your mobile applications
you need to expose api's out of it so
that's the monolithic legacy how many
people in the room deal with systems
that look like this half of the room
probably you might have you know kind of
progress from that step forward a little
bit and have built some facade services
you know that usually happens because
it's so hard and costly to change the
legacy for you know implementing new
features so you might you know adopt as
a Strangler pattern of building some
services around the legacy to expose a
more you know developer friendly set of
api's often is we see this architecture
in the boundary of the organization so
you have the digital part of the
organization's going with services and
you still have the corporate part of the
organization dealing with legacy
how many people have systems that
somewhat look like this okay you
probably have combination of those two
as well and and you know that there are
different revisions of this that you can
go through but at the end of the
spectrum you've got in a larger number
of services build around you that your
business capabilities and you've got a
you know a large number of
interconnectivity across your services
then it really doesn't matter that
service is sitting at the edge exposing
api's you know to different user
experiences or the service is some sort
of a core capability that other services
are using their equally services and
have the same kind of features so if you
look at this spectrum what sort of
characteristics we observe if you're at
the beginning of the journey
there aren't many inter system
connectivities if you are moving towards
micro services with larger number of
services you have you know the larger
number of interconnectivity what that
means is that those concerns like
resiliency and the tracing and you know
dynamic service discovery those are the
concerns that you really want to think
about and implement in your architecture
your mental model about security shifts
if you have a monolith with a bunch of
api's or even sometimes some facade
services you are comfortable with the
idea of security at the parameter I'm
going to put some zoning in place some
gateway in place and you know the the to
monitor the traffic coming in to secure
that but the network within our the
application that runs those business
logic I'm happy for it to be considered
anybody within their neck
I'm happy to be considered secure as we
move to the marker services you really
no matter how secure your network is
your mindset shifts to zero trust
environment where you want to
authenticate every service the service
call you want to authorize who can call
who and you want to authorize a nothing
to get the end-users on behalf of
actually running the services we have a
lot of clients that they do want mutual
TLS termination at every service between
every service they want to have off
between their services observability
changes right we on when you have just a
small set of API as a number of services
you care about observer ability at the
edge what calls are coming in what's a
repro response done to my clients what
are the failure rates but where the
micro services without observability at
every service we are be will be
operating in the dark we can't even
debug issues the next two ones are some
curious ones that um I really like when
this sort of mind shift happens people
who are starting from legacy and
building some services and API is they
have this strong separation between how
they treat their users a user of those
IPS if they're external and the user of
ApS if they're internal so if you have
some sort of external API users you care
about your API documentation how easy
people can find you know API is how easy
is the experience of writing a hello
world from you know I want to use an API
I found it I used it you know I can you
know get to the endpoint but if the
these are API is internally you probably
have to go knock on everybody's door to
find that if you have an API or not in
in my services what you really want an
equally delightful experience for all
your developers discovering the API is
you know using them and testing them
good documentation good testing and
finally this idea of what an API is kind
of changes for some reason when I talk
to people they think api's are these
magical things that we sprinkle around
the edge of our applications and it's
really at the edge of our suffer and
this this dichotomy and the
you know duality of the API is that we
expose to the client applications and
inter-service communication to me every
service the service communication is an
API in a micro-services api's are the
fabric of your integration whether it's
G RPC or rests you know with JSON or
events it's the surface how you surface
your capability of service so that's why
I I sometimes interchangeably use API
and services kind of to make my argument
so we have seen now the capabilities
that API management systems gives us we
have seen this kind of spectrum of the
architecture so what's the answer I
would have loved to come out today and
say there is a new great way of doing
API management and that service mission
is extension to it but I can't just say
that for a lot of us we are still in the
legacy world we you know we're dealing
with one monolithic applications and a
bunch of api's and you really what
you're looking for is a stopgap to get
the traffic between your client and your
back-end application under control you
probably just want to put you you
probably have a hard time changing that
monolith so you want to have an external
components that deals with some of the
you know gives you some of the observer
ability that you want at the edge as we
talked about some security of your api's
at the age and as you start moving to
kind of more proxy services if you still
haven't so there's a little bit of like
so some conditions to consider here if
you still haven't moved to the
containerized world you probably have
some sort of a contract with an existing
you know api gateway system but you want
to get those observability and you know
the rate limiting and api documentation
across the services that you have within
the organization this model would be a
small mutation to what you have which is
you know having the edge gateway for
your incoming traffic and
kind of a hub of gateways or proxies in
this case between between the services
some products that we've used in this
configuration and works really well to
Neymar for instance conch I don't know
if you guys have used the open source
API gateway Kong it's a it's a said
lightweight gateways built on top of
nginx so it's performs very well you
have to think about the performance if
this configuration because you've got
another network hub to go through across
all of your services so you really want
to test and the performance of the
Gateway but you pick and it's it's
fairly lightweight if you're serious
about building more services and
expanding on this I would say this is a
this has a very short runway for you to
because you want to kind of get into the
mesh world and be cognizant of the
community commitment that you have to
the product you choose go lightweight or
you know the costs that you're going to
incur to have this but if you are still
already in a world that you have an
educate where this this can be kind of
the progression to that model do we have
any people anybody in the room that has
this kind of hard proxy for inter
service within within your services
communication that you've applied the
same edge gateway product that you had
try to yeah trying to do right now okay
I'm just curious what for that's here
thank you okay okay yeah this is one
person trying yeah it's not a very kind
of well-known it is one of the large
retailers in us that I worked with a few
years back actually they had an H gate
they were bare very soon they decided
well we need all these capabilities
across our services as well so why can't
we put one of these in the middle the
problem is that most of the gateways
actually build both gateway and the
management into one product so you're
not going to be in a good position in
terms of the performance and the
configuration of these some have the
concept of micro gateways but
it's something to consider if you are
already in this in this space using
gateways I wouldn't jump into this if
you are building large number of
services so for any other case I would
say for inter service communication and
all those cross-cutting functions that
we mentioned to get visibility to get
you know security seriously consider
service mesh but then one question there
will be many questions because the next
question is ok which mesh will I pick
and we get to that in a minute as well
but there is a still one question stands
here is that we had a whole lot of other
bubbles if you remember around API
documentation and other capabilities
that meshes don't really provided that
they're not concerned with right at
least right now so how do we get those
ones does anybody have an answer because
I'm looking for the answer as well all
right so the answers are right now I
will tell you in this very interim place
we are because this is space is changing
very quickly is taken toolkit approach
so if you you're deciding to use the
service mesh then think about products
that open source or commercial on-prem
or SAS that gives you some of these
capabilities that you want for instance
you know swagger has been around for a
while in a SAS model or an on-prem and
that's a you know good enough product
for getting your documentation out to
the users there are a whole lot of
libraries if you go back to the
technology radar I refer to at the
beginning that you can use we've
published some of the other tooling that
comes with it for you know sanity
checking the API expect that you have
with the documentation and updating that
automatically if you want to use kind of
some of the other suspects read me on
that i/o it's and you start up again in
San Francisco they if you look at their
websites they give you a dynamic kind of
document generation with that kind of
nice three panel design that you can
connect to any any kind of back-end
services that you have
and I guess the hint here for people who
are up for innovation this is there is a
space for innovation here you know we
don't have a lot of good solutions so
any open systems that can't plug into
the service mission provide API gateways
it's it's gonna be an interesting one
the next maybe the next option again an
interim option is pick an API management
that you know supports the mesh and
there are different ways of supporting
the Michigan Khong as I mentioned
earlier they gone down the route of
actually with nginx being the Surfaris
API gateway that can run as a sidecar
itself the challenge with this model is
that unless you buy into Kong as a
sidecar you're not gonna get all the
other nice you know documentation and
the other management features so you
have to kind of buy into the proxy as
well as kind of the rest
there is another open-source software
out there I haven't really looked
closely added ambassador that claims to
also be an API gateway lightweight kind
of management solution for this but I
haven't personally look into it again
it's a it's not a well populated space
right now and finally you can wait and
see what happens in a short few months
is 20.3 they announced well there's zero
point one but in the two releases on the
roadmap they announced that they're
going to include API management
capabilities into the mesh so it would
be interesting to see how that happens
we might see with you know with Apogee
having joined Google or being built by
Google we might see some interesting
innovations there I'm not sure if I was
building one I would probably just get
out of the proxy or Gateway system and
just stick to the management
capabilities as back-end infrastructure
it's the same way that the premise
prometheus is a back-end infrastructure
gateway management systems could be a
back-end infrastructure without needing
to have you know another hub another
layer of tech into our architecture you
know
be very comprehensive to type like it's
actually you're gonna get into because
until this normalizes you will be
encouraged to insert these gateways
along the way that you may not kind of
need it and whether you are picking an
API gateway or a service mesh or
something in the middle there are five
principles that I would use personally
to choose a technology and kind of
advise the clients I work with and the
the first one is this idea of platform
thinking or platform this this anyone
have a good description of what platform
is what platform means to you some of
those hard ones we kind of can feel it
know what it is but it's very hard to
describe it to me it's an open ecosystem
where I can build things on top or I can
you know plug in things or capabilities
in and out with different technology SEO
is a really good example of an open
ecosystem embracing an open platform and
you know you can they have built
extension the kind of points where you
can plug in other technologies that you
have for instance you can get the
service discovery with kubernetes or if
you want and if you have invested in
console or zookeeper or other ways of
doing service discovery in your
infrastructure you can kind of adapt and
plug that in this is all in theory right
now focus it's very early but that's
kind of the intention of the
architecture and so every any product
that you you pick see if it passes that
kind of litmus test of the platform and
one of those litmus tests that you can
apply is that can I configure this
product with api's does this a you know
product embraces open standards or do I
need to come you know commit to a big
you know big bowl of proprietary
technology that I can't talk to anything
else a good example of API driven
approaches that for instance Kong is an
example to configure or you know to
publish your api's or to
you know secure them they build api's to
do that we we have we've been using that
in our build pipelines and you know kind
of automatically configuring the gateway
in a very simple model we've been using
it in the edge or kind of the hub model
the other product you might configure to
compare it to nginx this is great you
know Swiss Army kind of knot can do so
many things but you have to configure
this configuration via the you know you
might hurt yourself playing with the
next so just think about how the how the
product gets configured does it have an
API driven way of extending it and
configuring it embracing the open-source
that's a no-brainer but I want you to be
careful that not open-source is all open
sources equal it has become quite an
interesting kind of commercial model for
companies you know have a product and
then make that product open-source and
then they provide you you know
commercial support because you want to
call somebody if things fall apart and
get an answer but sometimes those open
source part I actually have no community
around them so think about the health of
the community of that you know open
source that commits how quickly the
issues are fixed who are the
contributors like you know pay attention
to that and embrace diversity diversity
is good in nature in society and in the
tech stack to be honest if you think
about the platforms that we talked about
that you can plug in and out some
different take stacks that you know
gives you the ability to try different
technology sometimes in organizations
you don't you you don't have a
consistent culture you have subcultures
within the organization you have
different skill sets within the
organization so trying to pick one
solution that suits everybody
you know forces us down the path of
least common denominator and what's
worse the whole world so diversity of
tech is not so bad as long as we are
adopting open standards for you know
connecting those pieces of Technology
together and lastly the most important
one for me would be embracing change
whatever technology that you would be
choosing today especially in this space
would change very quickly so think about
how you build an architecture that it's
designed for change it's a really
interesting book that have come out by
Rebecca Parsons and Neil Ford from Salt
Works called evolutionary architecture
has anybody heard of it already it's
already it's one person
oh no two person two people it's a
there's an interesting notion there the
fitness function that you apply to your
architecture taken from genetic
algorithms the objective function that
tells you how close you are to the
target model or the target system that
you want
I would pick change or ability to change
as a fitness function for my
architecture if I'm in this space
because you know things gonna change
very quickly and we want to be able to
kind of respond to that so that's all I
have to share at this one I'm sure this
stuff I could change in a few time a few
months so thank you for listening and
please reach out if you want to give any
feedback or comments um I'll be happy to
hear your questions
plug in thought works we're always hired
we are hiring kind of distributed
systems architectures delivering
infrastructure folks who are dealing
with the type of problems and challenges
that I talked about that's all they are
all different scales so if you're
interested to join us come and talk to
me or reach out thank you
[Applause]